شلت موجه اضرابات ومظاهرات مدنا فرنسيه
رفضا لقانون رفع سن التقاعد الذي تحاول
الحكومه فرضه وتواصل النقابات تحركاتها
ضده منذ اسابيع وتتزامن هذه الاحتجاجات
التي تخلل بعضها مواجهات مع اضراب في قطاع
النقل العام والمطارات في المانيا
للمطالبه بتحسين الاجور كما انها تاتي بعد
احتجاجات مطلبيه في اسبانيا واخرى في
بريطانيا والبرتغال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الاسباب التي قادت
الى تفجر موجه الاحتجاجات والاضرابات
العماليه والاجتماعيه الراهنه في العديد
من دول اوروبا وما فرص احتواء هذه
الاحتجاجات والاضرابات والتخفيف من
تداعياتها المحتمله على اوروبا وعلى الدول
المرتبطه بها
والى اي حد يمكن ان تدفع هذه الاضطرابات
الدول الاوروبيه لاعاده ترتيب اولوياتها
والموازنه بين الرفاهيه مواطنيها وبنود
الدعم المرتبطه بمواقفها من قضايا خارجيه
[موسيقى]
بموازاه اضرابات طالت قطاعات حيويه عديده
شملت حتى قطاع السياحه في فرنسا اجتاحت
المدن الفرنسيه يوم الثلاثاء مظاهرات
واسعه شهد بعضها مواجهات بين قوات الامن
والمتظاهرين احتجاجا على قانون رفع سن
التقاعد الذي تتواصل الاحتجاجات
والاجتماعيه والنقابيه عليه منذ فتره قبل
انضمام قوى سياسيه وازنه اليها ومع تاكيد
القوى النقابيه وبعض الاحزاب السياسيه
اصرارها على مواصله التظاهر الى ان تتراجع
الحكومه عن هذا القانون اتهمت اطراف في
الحكومه الفرنسيه جهات خارجيه بتاجيج تلك
الاحتجاجات التي دفعت الرئيس شرطه باريس
الى الحديث عن ما سماه رغبه البعض في خلق
مناخ تمرد وتصعيد الرديكاليه
احداث فرنسا تزامنت في بعض مراحلها مع
خروج الاف المواطنين الاسبان للاحتجاج على
خطط حكوميه لخفض الرعايه الصحيه العامه
واحتجاجات واضطرابات في بريطانيا للمطالبه
بتحسين الاجور والتمديد بغلاء المعيشه
اسباب دفعت عمال السكك الحديديه وشبكات
الطرق السريعه والمطارات في المانيا الى
اضراب وصفه بانه الاكبر منذ عقود وشل
اجساء واسعه من قطاع النقل في البلاد ورغم
تاثير الواسع على الاضراب الا ان قياده
عماليه اعتبرته مجرد عينه لما يمكن ان
يحدث اذا لم تستجب الحكومه لمطالب العمال
بتحسين ظروف العمل وزياده الاجور في مقابل
ارتفاع معدلات التضخم في المانيا
[موسيقى]
لمناقصه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس
الدكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس ومن جنوب
الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعات جونيف ابدا معك دكتور
زياد دكتور زياد لبريطانيا الى فرنسا الى
البرتغال في اسبانيا والمانيا احتجاجات
واضرابات هل من اسباب مشتركه دفعت الى
انفجار هذه الاحتجاجات في اوقات متزامنه
ان صح التعبير
هناك بالطبع اسباب مشتركه ترتبط بشعور
قطاعات واسعه من المجتمعات الاوروبيه بان
مساله العداله الاجتماعيه لم تعد اولويه
من اولويات الحكومات المختلفه تراث
العداله الاجتماعيه في اوروبا وقضايا
الضرائب التصاعديه وقوانين التقاعد
والرعايه الصحيه والتربيه المجانيه وغيرها
يجري في بعض الاحيان اما تقليص موازنتها
او التراجع عن مكتسبات خاضت نقابات لضلات
طويله تاريخيا الانتزاعها فهناك بالطبع
هذه المساله القائمه والمشتركه وهناك ايضا
ازمه اقتصاديه هي عالميه لكن في اوروبا
بسبب قضايا الطاقه بسبب ارتفاع بعض
الاسعار وبسبب تضخم يصيب بشكل عام السلل
الغذائيه للناس ايضا تتصاعد التحركات
نتيجه لذلك وربما هناك خصوصيه فرنسيه الان
بسبب القانون الذي تتقدم به الحكومه من
اجل رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما وبالتالي
فرض عامين اضافيين من العمل على طبقه وسطى
وطبقات دنيا تعاني اليوم كثيرا ويطلب منها
ان تعاني اكثر من اجل تمويل عجز ميزانيه
في حين يمكن لواحد في المئه من الضرائب
الاضافيه على الثروات الكبرى ان تكون
كافيه لمعالجه ذلك فهذه القضايا تنفجر في
الشارع والنقابات لديها حضور اساسي
وبالتالي
مظاهرات والميزه اعتقد في جميع العواصم
الاوروبيه او المدن الاوروبيه هي المشاركه
الواسعه للجيل الشاب طلاب وطالبات ثانويين
وجامعيين يشاركون ايضا بكثافه وهذا مؤشر
على مزاج يرتبط بجيلهم ويرتبط بالطبع
بتطلعاتهم طيب اشرت الى العداله
الاجتماعيه دكتور زياد يعني انخفاض الشعور
بالعداله الاجتماعيه لدى الحكومات هذا ليس
بجديد لكي يؤدي الى تزامن هذه الاحتجاجات
مع بعضها البعض واشرت ايضا الى العامل
الاقتصادي ما الاسباب التي ادت الى هذا
الضغط الاقتصادي داخل هذه الدول ما دفع
الحكومات الرئيس ماكرون يقول الازمه
الاقتصاديه هي التي تدفعه الى رفع سن
التقاعد على سبيل المثال
يعني اولا بشكل عام الخريطه السياسيه
الاوروبيه
ذهبت نحو اليمين منذ سنوات طويله او نحو
خطاب جديد يدعي انه وسطي ويحاول او يقول
انه يريد ان يضاعف من الانتاج وان يوسع
حجم الثروات كي يستطيع الاستمرار
بتوزيع بسياسات الاجتماعيه هذا التطور في
خطاب الحكومات وممارساتها ليس جديدا انما
بدات الان اثاره تظهر بشكل واضح لجهه
اتساع الهواه بين الطبقات ولجهه تركز
الثروه عند اقليه في حين لم يكن الامر على
هذا النحو قبل عشر سنوات او 15 عاما او
اكثر اوروبا اصبحت تشبه بهذا المعنى اكثر
فاكثر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا ما
لا يقبله جزء كبير من الاوروبيين ليس كل
الاوروبيين بطبيعه الحال لكن بلا شك ان
اثار الحرب في اوكرانيا الان وارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه بسبب هذه الحرب تضاعف من
التحديات وتدفع نحو المزيد من التوترات
بسبب ارتفاع الاسعار وبسبب الغضب من هذا
الارتفاع فقط ملاحظه ماكرون يتحجج بذلك
لكن هذه خطته منذ ما قبل حرب اوكرانيا
تراجع عنها في عهده الاول في الولايه
الاولى الان في الولايه الثانيه لانه غير
معني باعاده انتخابه يستطيع ان يذهب ابعد
فيما كان يريد فعله في الولايه الاولى ولم
يتمكن وقتها لذلك يريد الان قبل ان تنتهي
ولايته الثانيه ان يسجل ما يعده انجازا في
اعاده ترتيب المسائل الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه بالطريقه التي تشبه
ايديولوجيته دكتور حسني هل اثار الحرب على
اوكرانيا هي سبب مباشر لهذا الضغط
الاقتصادي في دول اوروبيه ما ادى الى
الاحتجاجات والاضرابات ام هي مجموعه عوامل
كلها ادت الى هذه الاحتجاجات
هناك العديد من العوامل يعني هناك تراكم
اسباب اقتصاديه على المستوى المحلي وعلى
المستوى الدولي يعني فرنسا مثلا كمثال
وربما كذلك سنسوق المانيا حجم المديونيه
وصل الى درجات قياسيه لا يمكن في النهايه
للاقتصاد الفرنسي ان فقط له الا ان يعالج
قضيه خدمه المديونيه ويعني هذه القصه منذ
سنوات يعني من قبل الرئيس ماكرون النقطه
الثانيه اعتقد الوعي القضيه الاساسيه
بالنسبه للنقطه المشتركه وعنوان كل
الاحتجاجات هي انخفاض القدره الشرائيه لكن
لماذا الان لماذا الان لان بصفه مختصره
لعمال يحسون الان بان درجه او البطاله
انخفضت في كل الدول الاوروبيه يعني هناك
حاجه للعماله الداخليه وبالتالي
العمال يحسون بان هذه اللحظه السانحه من
اجل
المطالبه بشروط لتحسين الاقتصادي لان
القدره الشرائيه انهارت الاسباب هناك
اسباب كما قلت اسباب يعني قديمه داخل
اقتصاديات الاوروبيه منها ما يتعلق
بالوحده الاوروبيه منها ما متعلق اصلا
ببعض الخوض الخوصصه التي كذلك قضت على جزء
كبير من ما يسمى بالصناعات التحويليه
الاكمه من المؤكد ان اللعب اللعب المالي
للحرب في اوكرانيا بعد كذلك بعد
المالي بعد كورونا بعد جائحه كورونا اثر
بدرجه متفاوته على كل الاقتصاديات
الاوروبيه خاصه تلك الدول وبالمناسبه هي
نفس الدول التي تعيش الان ازمات فرنسا
المانيا اسبانيا بالاضافه الى ايطاليا
كانت من الدول التي فعلا سخرت ميزانيات
ضخمه وضختها في الاقتصاديات حتى حتى تحاول
معالجه واحتواء كل الاثار الاجتماعيه
الاقتصاديه لازمه كورونا الان جاءت كذلك
ازمه كورونا مع العبر عفوا اوكرانيا اضافت
عبء كبير يعني تحدثت عن مجموعه من الاسباب
منها كورونا وايضا الحرب المديونيه على
هذه التي كانت تعاني منها هذه الدول اساسا
ولكن اذا ما اخذنا اثار الحرب على
اوكرانيا يعني اي مرتبه تحتل على سلم
الاسباب المؤديه لهذه الاضطرابات
الاجتماعيه في هذه الدول
يعني نعترف يعني لكل دوله تقريبا لديها
خصوصيه صحيحه ان اسعار الطاقه ارتفعت
كثيرا يعني في بعض الدول مثل بريطانيا
خمسين بالمئه في فرنسا ما بين 16 وخمسه
وعشرين بالمئه فمن المؤكد ان اسعار ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه ساهمت كذلك في انخفاض القدره
الشرائيه للمواطن الاوروبي في كل هذه
الدوله تستورد هذه السلعه في نفس الوقت
انا اعتقد انه الاسباب لا يمكن فقط جعلها
من ناحيه من ناحيه اوكرانيا الحرب على
اوكرانيا او كذلك
الانفاق العسكري الكبير جدا على
التسليح وانما اعتقد ان الحرب في اوكرانيا
في النهايه
وتخصيص ميزانيات فخمه من اجل التصلح خاصه
في المانيا التي ضاعفت ميزانيه الميزانيه
المسلحه لديها تاثيرات كبيره على الجانب
الاقتصادي والجانب الاجتماعي نقطه اخيره
هي نقطه مهمه اعتقد هي فقدنا في النهايه
ذلك ذاك الطاقم السياسي يعني الان اصبح
هناك اداء اداري ايداء فني لازمات متراكمه
اقتصاديا وسياسيا وكذلك عسكريين للاسف لا
في المانيا بعد بعد المستشاره بركل ولا
كذلك في فرنسا ولا حتى في اسبانيا لم نشهد
يعني رجال سياسيين يعني فعلا في مستوى
التحديات المطروحه ولذلك هناك ازمه كبيره
كيف يمكن معالجه هذه الازمه في النهايه
برجالهم
في النهايه اداريين فنيين او بنكيين مثلا
مثل رئيس
معالجه هذه الاسماء ولكن دعني اسمع من
الدكتور زياد ماجد الدكتور زياد لانفاق
العسكري في الكثير من الدول على سبيل
المثال المانيا لم يمنعها من ضخ مبالغ
طائله في الاقتصاد من اجل تحفيز الاقتصاد
وانعاشه يعني 220 مليار على ما اعتقد
دولار تم تم ضخها في الاقتصاد لمساعده
الطبقات الاكثر فقرا ومن هم بحاجه لهذا
الدعم الانفاق العسكري ودعم اوكرانيا
بالاموال الى اي مدى اثر على اقتصادات هذه
الدول وعلى ميزانياتها من ناحيه الطاقه
نعلم ذلك ارتفعت بعض الاسعار الى 80% على
سبيل المثال في بريطانيا ارتفعت تكلفه
الطاقه لكل منزل
انا لا اعتقد ان الموازنات العسكريه هي
سبب ما يجري اليوم لان اثارها لن تظهر هذا
العام ولا حتى العام المقبل تظهر بعد
اعوام
وفرنسا مثلا لم تنفق الكثير عسكريا على
اوكرانيا وهذا يؤخذ عليها هي في مرتبه
متاخره جدا بين الدول الاوروبيه التي تدعم
الاوكرانيين العسكريا وماريا المانيا طبعا
قبلها بكثير ودول مثل بولونيا او حتى دول
مثل ليتوانيا وفي اوروبا الشرقيه هناك
الكثير من الدول التي تتقدم فرنسا انفاقا
عسكريا يرتبط
بالاجتياح الروسي لاوكرانيا لكن بلا شك ان
الاثار الجانبيه او المرتبطه بالحرب
لجهات الطاقه كما تفضلتي وتفضل ضيفك لجهه
ارتفاع الاسعار مساله القدره الشرائيه
بسبب التضخم هي ايضا العنصر ضاغط وهناك
مناخ خوف ربما ينعكس على الاسواق الماليه
عالميا بسبب الحرب ويؤدي الى مشاكل اضافيه
الى توقعات او الى مراهنات بدورها تضع
ضغطا على عدد من الاقتصادات لكن موضوع
المديونيه هو موضوع اساسي موضوع الانفاق
الاجتماعي وازمه كورونا بينت ان دولا
كثيره حتى التي كان فيها
اقتصاد اشتراكي مع حضور اساسي مثل فرنسا
لم تكن احوال المستشفيات جيده كانت تتطلب
دعما كبيرا يؤخذ على ماكرون وحكوماته انها
لم تقم به حتى الان موضوع التعليم
والتربيه هي من المواضيع الحيويه
والاساسيه في المجتمعات الاوروبيه
والمطالبه بها عاليه ثم هناك في الحاله
الالمانيه مسائل بيئيه تلعب دورا كبيرا في
الحسب التعبي نراه في مدن معينه العوده
الى مناجم الفحم العوده الى اساليب كان
البيئيون يريدون تخطيها لكن ازمه الطاقه
اليوم تفرض عوده اليها طبعا المساله
النوويه ايضا النوويه السلميه كل هذا يضع
الكثير من الامور امام ضغوط وامامه شد
حبال سياسي ونقابي واجتماعي وفيما يخص
بريطانيا اعتقد ان
له اثر اعمق بكثير من الحرب الاوكرانيه
على الاقتصاد البريطاني وعلى الحسابات
الخاطئه التي دفعت جزءا من البريطانيين
للتصويت لصالح
والان اثاره صارت ظاهره عندهم في الكثير
من الامور وعلى
دكتور زياد دكتور حسني طيب ما هي قدره هذه
الحكومات
على احتواء
الازمه وهل هنا نستطيع ان نجمع ان كل هذه
الحكومات في بوطقه واحده ام ان قدره حكومه
تختلف عن قدره حكومه اخرى مثلا بالمقارنه
بين المانيا وفرنسا على سبيل على سبيل
المثال بولندا حكومه اخرى ودوله اخرى
اقتصادها مختلف تركيبه الاقتصاد مختلفه
وقدره هذه الدوله مختلفه
التجاوب سيكون مختلفا يعني المانيا لديها
هامش من الحركه اكبر بكثير من الهامش الذي
تتمتع به فرنسا اولا ان القرار هو قرار لا
مركزي ما بين اللمبات وما بين كذلك
الحكومه الفيدراليه واعتقد في اضراب مثلا
قطاع النقل سيتم حله
موافقه على زياده الاسعار
بخمسه بالمئه تمت موافقه عليه لكن
المظاهرات تطالب
بعشره بالمئه لالمانيا القدره في النهايه
للاستجابه في فرنسا عقد الموضوع مختلف
تماما هناك نوع من الاستعلاء اداره الرئيس
مكرونه لهذه الازمه مشكله ليس فقط قانون
المعاشات الذي هو يعني يعني معارضته واصبح
يعني معارضه كبيره الرئيس ماكرون شعبيته
وصلت الى ادنى مستوى يعني تقريبا وصلت الى
تعبتي هي عندما عند مظاهرات
السطرات الصفراء يعني تقريبا 26 وثمانيه
وعشرين بالمئه هو لم يقبل بمرور هذا
القانون عبر البرلمان استعمل كما تعلمين
ما يسمى بالقانون
ثلاثه للقانون 49 المرور من غير التصويت
عليه من خلال البرلمان ثم قال في النهايه
لن يقبل بشرعيه الشارع بان شرعيه الشارع
لا تضاهي شرعيه في نهايه الانتخابات وهو
نسي انه في النهايه تم التصويت عليه
باقليه وانما صوت عليه لان كان
المشاركه الثاني هو هي مارين لوبان الحزب
اليمني المتطرف ولم يرغب فيها الفرنسيون
فنعتقد ان التجاوب سيكون مختلف كثير فرنسا
في ازمه كبيره لان الرئيس ماكرون لا يريد
التراجع على هذا القرار وفي نفس الوقت
اعتقد ان الاحزاب السياسيه خاصه احزاب
اليسار وجزء من احزاب اليمين بالاضافه الى
النقابات لا يمكن في النهايه ان يتنازل في
ذلك في النهايه انتهاك ليس فقط للدستور
وانما في حقهم كذلك في في التظاهر ولذلك
يعني
التلويح بقضيه التمرد الى غير ذلك هي بعض
اساليب من اجل تخويف واذا وصلت اذا استمرت
المظاهرات يعني الاسبوع المقبل قد سيكون
هناك يعني شيئا ما في فرنسا لانه لا يمكن
لفرنسا ان تستمر على هذا النحو من
المظاهرات هذا فيما يتعلق باسبانيا
والمانيا دكتور زياد ماذا عن عفوا هذا
فيما يتعلق بفرنسا والمانيا ولكن ماذا عن
بريطانيا ماذا عن اسبانيا ما قدرت هذه
الحكومات على التخفيف من تداعيات الازمه
الاقتصاديه على دولها
الحاله الاسبانيه ايضا حاله مختلفه لان
الاقتصاد الاسباني اصغر لكن اسبانيا هي
بدورها دوله فيدراليه ويمكن لموازنات
اوروبيه احيانا ان تلعب دورا في تخفيف
الاحتقان او في تخفيف بعض الصعوبات
الاقتصاديه لكن اعتقد ان القاره الاوروبيه
بشكل عام ستشهد المزيد من التحركات
الاجتماعيه بسبب ثقافه سياسيه جديده لم
تعد تدخل من خلال الاحزاب التقليديه فقط
وانما ايضا من خلال حركات الاجتماعيه
من الحركات الاجتماعيه هل سيؤدي ذلك الى
تغيير اولويات هذه الدول خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالتزاماتها الخارجيه
لا انا يعني مره اخرى اعتقد ان الالتزامات
الخارجيه ليست موضعه تنازع كبير هناك في
اوروبا شعور عام ان روسيا هي خطر وبالتالي
سبل التعامل مع هذا الخطر يمكن ان تختلف
بين طرف وطرف اذا استثنينا اليمين المتطرف
الذي بمعظم حيوياته هو اقرب للموقف الروسي
لكن لم يعد يستطيع المجاهره بذلك بسبب
الحرب انما السياسه الخارجيه الاوروبيه
قد اكثر تشددا في قضايا الهجره في قضايا
اللاجئين وهذا امر قائم منذ فتره ويمكن ان
يستمر لكن التموضع الدولي لاوروبا ليس
الان مطروحا كاولويا لا لدى الحكومات ولا
لدى الحركات الاجتماعيه التي تريد ادبيات
سياسيه باختصار
من التحديات له علاقه بهويتها
بالمساله الايرلنديه
يعني هل هل اوروبا قادره على التوفيق بين
خياراتها الخارجيه ورفاهيه مواطنيها
باختصار لو سمحت
يعني هذه من خصائص النظام الديمقراطي انا
اعتقد هناك توزيع للادوار لكن اتفق معك في
نقطه وهي قضيه انه سيكون هناك انهاك كبير
لقاطيره طيله حاد اوروبي من الصعب جدا على
فرنسا التي تتبوا مناصب اوليه اساسيه في
السياسه الخارجيه وبالاضافه كذلك المانيا
الاستمرار على نفس الوتيره وسيتم تحديد
الاولويات حسب معطيات قبل كل شيء الشارع
الفرنسي والشارع الالماني شكرا لك دكتور
حسني عبيدي استاذه علاقات الدوليه بجامعه
جناف والشكر موصول للدكتور زياد ماجد
استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعات
الامريكيه في باريس
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]